find the volume of a sphere with the
diameter of 14 centimeters so if I have
a sphere so this isn't just a circle
this is a sphere you could view it as a
globe of some kind so I'm going to shade
it a little bit so you can tell that
it's three-dimensional they're giving us
the diameter so if we go from one side
of the sphere straight through the
center of its or imagining that we can
see through the sphere and we go
straight through the centimeter that
distance right over there is 14
centimeters now to find the volume of a
sphere we prove this or you will see a
proof for this later when you learn
calculus but the formula for the volume
of a sphere is volume is equal to 4/3 PI
R cubed where R is the radius of the
sphere so they've given us the diameter
and just like for circles of the radius
of the sphere the radius of the sphere
is half of the diameter so in this
example our radius is going to be 7
centimeters in fact the sphere itself is
the set of all points in three
dimensions that is exactly the radius
away from the center but with that out
of the way let's just apply this radius
being 7 centimeters to this formula
right over here so we're going to have a
volume is equal to 4/3 pi times 7
centimeters to the third power so I'll
do that in that pink color so times 7
centimeters to the third power and since
it already involves pi and you could
approximate PI with 3.14 some people
even approximate it with 22 over 7 but
we'll actually just get the calculator
out to get the exact value for this
volume so this is going to be this is
going to be so my volume is going to be
4/3 and then I don't want to just put a
PI there because that might interpret it
as 4/3 PI so 4/3 times pi times pi times
times 7 to the third power and order of
operations it'll do the exponent before
it does the multiplication so this
should work
and the units are going to be in
centimeters cubed or cubic centimeters
so we get 14 36 they don't tell us what
to round it to so I'll just round it to
the nearest 10th 14 36.8 so this is
equal to four one thousand four hundred
thirty six point eight centimeters cubed
and we're done